according to the conservative majority
on the U.S Supreme Court President Biden
did not have the legal authority to
forgive some 400 billion dollars of
student debt under the heroes Act of
2003 which allows student debt payments
to be waived in emergencies like a
pandemic The Proposal affected 40
million borrowers earning less than 125
000 a year although 90 earned less than
75 000 a year it forgave up to twenty
thousand dollars repayments have been on
hold since 2020 but now borrowers will
have to resume payments in October
achieve those Milestones such as like
buying a car or starting a family or
buying a home with covet people had the
opportunity to try to catch up but since
the repayments are going to be starting
again soon it's going to put people back
into that hole that they were into not
being able to start their lives or
provide for their family or even provide
for themselves quickly as possible
speaking of the White House President
Biden said the administration will now
start the long legal process again this
time attempting to forgive student debt
using the Higher Education Act of 1965
which gives the government a firmer
legal basis to forgive student debt
in addition the president announced that
those facing difficulty repaying their
debts from October won't have their
credit rating affected for 12 months the
president said the Republicans opposing
pandemic student debt forgiveness were
Hypocrites let's be clear
some of the same elected Republicans
members of Congress who strongly opposed
can release the students got hundreds of
thousands of dollars themselves and
really members of Congress
because of the businesses they were able
to keep open
several members of Congress got over a
million dollars Biden is struggling in
the polls with younger voters who say
he's failed to keep a range of campaign
promises from 2020. this is the latest
disappointment and some activists have
long argued the administration
mishandled the issue by not using the
Higher Education Act in the first place
for them it will not be enough to make
this a campaign issue now in 2024. they
want Biden to act boldly now through
executive order to stop the need for
repayments in October and if he doesn't
act what about support for him in the
election I can't say that and I'm not
sure how young adults will vote but he
can expect that he will hear from
Advocates should he not fulfill his
promise the Biden Administration is
reported to be hoping that this issue
May mobilize this affected young voters
to the polls in 2024 amid his dismal
popularity ratings the argument the
Republicans are against all student debt
loan forgiveness at least Biden tried
Al Jazeera Washington